actually I'm the Nostalgia Critic also
known as that guy with the glasses also
known as Douglas Tyrion and you're going
to talk about this Harry Potter event
that I went to and I should say the way
we came up with it or I came up with is
that um I really heard that day the
night this was going on that there's
some sort of that the last book was
gonna be released less Harry Potter book
I remember though he's hearing people
wait in line and dress up and stuff like
that so I thought maybe I should cover
this and I called my friend Margo I
asked if he could do the camera work he
says I don't know is it worth it and
even I even I wasn't really sure and he
calls back and he says it turns out in
Oak Park which is very close to where we
live they're having the largest
gathering in the United States Harry
Potter fans because this is where it
started in America it started in this
bookstore in Oak Park and so he shook
his head pretty much said we have to do
this now don't we and I said yeah I
think we do so literally the majority of
this is improvised I think about like
you know 90 95 percent of it is just
made up on the spot
entra this woman here is the owner of
the bookstore you know if she couldn't
just sit back you know sell books and so
she had to be outside moderating lines
and stuff like that felt very bad for
her but she was very nice and even
though you know I'm making fun of these
people on stuff like that and everyone
calls some weirdos and stuff I guess a
these were very very nice people and had
a great sense of humor to them even if
they were a little odd to say the least
but you know that my guess is that this
probably stranger people it was
incredible I mean look at that street
the whole street is just filled with
people you know just a kid - Harry
Potter and I I have not read any of the
Harry Potter books I saw the movies and
I didn't really get into them I'm sure
the books are good but yeah I'm not huge
fancy guy so I never never did quite get
into that
surprisingly that hasn't gotten too many
bad marks oh this kid actually was
really really funny but we had to cut a
lot entry all of what he said because a
for time restrictions and B it was hard
to hear him you know that the sound I
love is isn't that good way to put
captions everywhere and stuff but by Roy
he was pretty funny he actually had some
good comebacks and everything so I felt
bad that we had to keep him out of the
video okay here's a secret for you this
scene right here is actually not at Oak
Park this is done actually in my
backyard at night which is not to say
this wasn't done at Oak Park
well actually this part wasn't I had
this idea and I want to do is where I
eat all the jelly beans but nobody was
selling the jelly beans I couldn't
believe it they're selling all this
Harry Potter crap and they weren't
selling the most popular item the jelly
beans so I just came back and I said
okay let's just film this outside let's
and sound effects you know it's like I'm
still at Oak Park so so somehow that
worked out yeah I still didn't get this
they the line starts at 11 o'clock at
the bookstore and yet the one of the
library was open until like you know the
morning or something I have no idea how
that works
I don't know why candle was there it was
really weird
as you can see like I say I mean these
people are very nice and very
cooperative and stuff like that I mean
even when I cut in line here I mean that
the girls are kind of laughing and stuff
like that but they're not really you
know nobody was that to get a shoot me
or anything though there was a cop there
you can probably see with a gun I think
the only thing that was really prepared
was obviously the hairy fire cliffnotes
which I had there which it turns out is
the reason why the mumble Netcom guys
talked to us because they saw that
envelope and they heard rumors that
people were going around ruining the end
of the book by shouting out the ending
so they thought I was going to do that
so they agreed to the interviewer and it
was literally they just walked by and I
just called him up like just said they
talked to me talk to me and you know
they did I didn't even know who they
were to be honest I guess they're
Ventura Harry Potter
next to JK Rowling they're like the most
popular people associated with the books
so I mean I really just looked out there
that hill music you can even see they
that they questioned me about it they're
like you know are those cliff notes what
are you up to and stuff like that as you
can see that obviously very funny people
and these guys were being treated like
superstars there were girls screaming
for him they were signing books I guess
they wrote books and you know I mean
these people were like the celebrities
of the night it was it was very
interesting so I think I really lucked
out I can't get chance to talk to him
and this seemed to is done outside not
outside my backyard now we actually did
shoot this at Oak Park but it just
didn't look good the sound was really
cracking up they were there too many
people talking so we decided I mean it's
the exact same dialogue I mean nothing
is different except the location so I
don't think it's really cheating I think
you know it's just making it look better
and sound better and I still have no
idea what sense this makes it's reserved
well I stay in the line if it's reserved
I mean what I don't know I felt bad for
the bookshop too because they're the
people I started in yet everybody lines
up outside the library and I thought
that was kind of a rip I found out that
they actually overstocked on all these
books and the next day I think actually
the next day when I went to film the
jellybeans thing I went I got some jelly
beans I saw a ton of those books and I
said I'm surprised you still have some
and the bookstore said that every
bookstore you can imagine overstocked so
it's probably not good for business but
I'm sure they sold them in the end
oh and this guy yeah I felt so bad
insulting him he was just he wasn't even
part of the show he just comes out he's
wearing his normal wear its kilt and I'm
making fun of him say he's one of the
Harry Potter fans and it's just a normal
guy walking about you know the streets
Andy right here's this jackass comes in
a you know hat and tymek in front of
them but like I say you can see he's
having a good laugh at it
and make for a cup of great Brown joke
[Music]
all right and at this scene I had no
idea what I was gonna do if I didn't
even know if the bit was working I can't
say do you want to go home you really
want to stay here as Tom I can't
remember Sadie's it's day let's see we
can get out of this and we got to this
point everything what we gonna do and I
said I'm just gonna go insane I'm gonna
scream at the top of my lungs and go
roll around the floor I'm gonna go nuts
I saw this group of girls right next to
me look at me as I said that and I don't
think I've ever seen a group of girls
get away from me so fast they've just
heard what I was gonna do and they just
they frantically fled the grin so of
course this is the part everybody loves
the most is this me screaming and yes
that's really my scream I I can get my
voice that high and on the book here
enter the couple coming out here I asked
can I just use this book for something
I'm filming and he said sure and when I
start to walk off here they thought I
was gonna steal a ten we cut right
before they run across the camera saying
hey tip the book back and I really did
lose my hat at this gets gamers kind of
sucks but you know it's fine but the tie
on my head like I went through something
incredible like Rambo or something so
and that was the Harry Potter get
together